So what else do we to tell the students, James?
>> Just how we'll be working in this course.
We'll be using two main tools, a text editor to code and
a browser to inspect our work.
All modern browsers include a powerful set of tools.
Commonly referred to as Developer Tools.
Which let's Developers inspect the way a website loads and runs.
Dev Tools also includes a console that allows you to
issue JavaScript commands against your website.
Let's give it a try.
>> Cool.
What do you have in mind?
>> Let's open up developer tools right now and run a command.
Let's say console.log();.
>> All right.
This sounds like a good time for a quiz.
Let's find out what console.log(); does.
I want you to pull up the console and type console.log("Hello world!");.
What happened when you ran the command?
Type it in here.